they stolen the house the people's house
that hallowed chamber our forefathers
created to both represent the people as
well as be closest to the people they've
hijacked it to maintain power for
themselves they don't work for or
represent you in fact they obstruct the
work that they were sent to do by you so
they can score their own political
points and get the revenge they so
desperately seek because they hate our
commander-in-chief these radicals who
have forfeited their job representing
you continue to resist create havoc and
claim constitutional crisis we've talked
for a long time about approaching a
constitutional crisis we are now in it
we are now in a constitutional crisis
you agree with Cartman Adler chairman
Tattler that there were no
constitutional crisis we are ever wonder
what a constitutional crisis looks like
we'll open your eyes I do believe we
have now entered that constitutional
crisis I'm really curious because isn't
that the height of a constant isn't the
definition of a constitutional crisis
President Trump appears to be heading
toward a constitutional crisis with
House Democrats as he continues to hide
the Moller report this administration
wants to have a constitutional crisis
constitutional crisis how because they
can't get the full molar report are they
all stupid
they have 98% of the full report and
I've got news for you bozos you weren't
even entitled to any of it the report
was written for the Attorney General by
the special counsel the Attorney General
decided to issue a four-page conclusion
and offered skeptical Democrats ask if a
secure facility to see the whole report
not one Democrat wanted to see it so
Attorney General Barr was in the
impossible position of violating federal
law and releasing 6e grand jury
testimony or acquiescing to the demands
of the radical Looney left folks the
only constant
to tional crisis is the one created by
Obama administration officials of a
false Russia collusion spun by that
master of deceit himself Jim Comey the
disgraced former head of the FBI we find
out this week the FBI was on full notice
the steel dossier was fake even before
they brought it to a FISA judge and use
it as the sole basis to spy on the Trump
campaign that Prince of Darkness himself
Comey knew all along the dossier was a
fraud even admitting to the president in
January 2017
it was unverified yet this subversive
used it to spy on the man that he and
his PI the felts didn't deserve to
occupy the Oval Office Comey has the
Clinton clan hutzpah saying this week we
don't spy we investigate Jim who are you
kidding
the dossier was biessing and knew it the
FBI knew it was a political document
that even had to get done before the
election certainly not an intelligence
document yet you signed three warrant
applications based on this fake dossier
you the FBI
the DOJ committed a fraud on the FISA
Court a massive abuse of power a clear
violation of our laws and yet you come
out of the shadows Thursday night
because you know the jig is up yes I
think spying did occur I believe there
is a basis for my concern I think spying
on a political campaign is a big deal
the application for the warrant you
presented as verified with a political
document to protect your girlfriend
Hillary who you your insubordinate self
as the IG concluded cut loose saying she
had no intent to violate the law and you
have the nerve to say when asked if
President Trump obstructed justice it
sure looks like it
Jim you wouldn't know obstruction of
justice
as if it slapped you in the face your
girlfriend Hillary obstructed justice
she destroyed evidence by lying deleting
30,000 emails destroying phones with
hammers and bleach pit so we wouldn't
know the truth and yet the disparate
treatment of Donald Trump is stunning in
a fake Russia collusion claimed there
were 3600 subpoenas 500 search warrants
investigations affecting 30 countries
500 witnesses questioned 18 lawyers 40
investigators criminal grand juries and
paneled the President himself handed
over 1.4 million documents and never
claimed executive privilege he was
harassed threatened persecuted hounded
tormented insulted and provoked his
family the same and you Cardinal call me
dare to show your face in public so
build bar is now held in contempt by the
same Congress that says to hell with the
American people and their work we want a
muddy up bar so when he starts indict us
we can say it's all political it's no
wonder that almost 80% of Americans do
not approve of the work that Congress is
doing I personally think that if these
guys don't do the work we sent them
there for they shouldn't get a salary
they shouldn't get a pension nor should
they be allowed to go on junkets or get
free health care and if you don't
approve of the gamesmanship going on in
the House of Representatives in the
swamp find out who your representative
is you can send a letter or an email or
just pick up the phone but I doubt
they'll care the only paper they respond
to is this and don't limit yourself to
those in your district we are one
country one America if you don't like
what they're doing find out who's
running against them whether it's in a
primary or a general election and get
involved let your voice be heard and
most importantly
start gearing up for 2020 we need a
House of Representatives that represents
the people in this great nation not the
people who want to remake America and
maintain their own power god help us
and God help us if we elect these same
people and they stay in control of our
country and that's my open tell me what
you think on my Facebook and Twitter
hashtag judge Janine